الله
اكبر في السابع من اكتوبر يوم ان اثبتت
حماس كم يبدو الهجوم على اسرائيل سهلا
بهذه الكلمات عنونت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
تحقيقها في ملابسات ما حدث ذلك اليوم
وعنوانه فشل الجيش الاكثر تقدما في الشرق
الاوسط في مهمته الاساسيه حمايه حياه
الاسرائيليين يتفاخر ضباط الجيش
الاسرائيلي بان الخرسانه المستخدمه لبناء
الجدار الحدودي مع القطاع كافيه لبناء
طريق سريع من غزه الى بلغاريا بعد اشهر
يتجاوز
1500 من مقاتلي حماس الجدار وبطائق شراعيه
لا يتجاوز سعر الواحده منها بضعه مئات
الدولارات بدات العمليه العسكريه المفاجئه
التي قادتها حماس وسمتها طوفان الاقصى
بقصف الاف الصواريخ على مدن غلاف غزه
وصولا الى تل ابيب ولتكس صفارات الانذار
سمت القدس المحتله ايذانا ببدء حدث
استثنائي في تاريخ اسرائيل الممتد ل 75
عاما بحسب كتائب القسام فان التعليمات
لمقاتليها كانت مهاجمه غرفه عمليات غزه
واسرا اكبر عدد من جنود الاحتلال لكنها
تفاجات من سرعه الانهيار الامني في مدن
الغلاف لتتسع رقعه الهجوم من البلدات
والمستوطنات المتاخمه لحدود القطاع الى ما
هو ابعد استخباراتيا عسكر وسياسيا اتهامات
بالفشل الذي بدا صادما للاسرائيليين
والعالم اكثر من هجوم حماس نفسه فماذا حدث
في ذلك اليوم وما هي ابعاد العمليه وهل
تلاعبت حماس حقا باسرائيل
استخباراتيا وفقا لنيويورك تايمز فان
المؤسسه الامنيه في تل ابيب حصلت قبل اكثر
من عام على وثيقه سريه من 40 صفحه سميت
بوثيقه جدار اريحا تتضمن خطه مفصله لتنفيذ
هجوم من غير مسبوق ضد اسرائيل شبيه بهجوم
السابع من اكتوبر تتحدث الوثيقه بشكل اكثر
دقه عن وابل من الصواريخ وطائرات من دون
طيار تدمر كاميرات امنيه يليها عبور
مقاتلين الى الجانب الاسرائيلي بمظلات
وسيارات وسيرا على الاقدام وفي يوليو تموز
الماضي اي قبل الهجوم بثلاثه اشهر حذرت
مجنده من وحده استخبارات النخبه
8200 من ان تدريبات عسكر
تجريها حماس على الحدود تحاكي خطه الهجوم
التي تحدثت عنها وثيقه جدار اريحا قبلت
هذه المعلومات بادنى قدر من الاهتمام
الامني داخل اجهزه المخابرات والجيش حتى
ان جنرالات في فرقه غزه استهزئوا بهذه
المعلومات ووصفوا الخطه بانها محض خيال
تام في احدى تحقيقاتها تسرد صحيفه هرتس ما
حصل ليله السابع من اكتوبر اي قبل ساعات
من الهجوم اذ دخل مسؤولون عسكريون من
قياده الجيش والشباك في مشاورات عاجله بعد
تحذيرات بان حماس بصدد تنفيذ هجوم في داخل
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه انتهت المشاورات
باعتماد راي رئيس الشباك بان حماس كانت
تجري مناورات فقط ولا تستعد لهجوم داخل
اسرائيل يحدد معهد الحروب الحديثه اسبابا
ثلاثه لفشل الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه في
التنبؤ بهجوم السابع من اكتوبر
فالاسيكلوفير استهانوا بقدرات حماس وترسخ
اعتقاد لديهم بان تفوقهم العسكري قادر على
صد اي هجوم الفرضيه السائده ان نتنياهو
وجهاز الشباك وحتى الجيش اساؤوا فهم نيات
حماس المبيته حتى ان نتنياهو اقنع نفسه
بان حماس قد ردعت تماما بعد مواجهه
2021 وانها رغيبه في حكم غزه فقط تقول
نيويورك تايمز ان فكره قيام حماس بتنفيذ
هجوم كانت مستبعده تماما الى حد ان مسؤولي
المخابرات الاسرائيليه خفضوا التنس على
الاتصالات اللاسلكيه للحركه وخلصوا الا ان
ذلك كان مضيعه للوقت انعكس ما وصف بالفشل
الاستخباراتي الاسوا لاسرائيل منذ حرب 33
فوضى وشلال عسكريا في مستوطنات غلاف غزه ل
ساعه رعيم موطن فرقه غزه التي تشرف على
جميع العمليات العسكريه في القطاع تقول
نيويورك تايمز ان بعض ضباط وجنود فرقه غزه
لم يعرفوا انهم يتعرضون للهجوم الا عندما
دخل مقاتل حماس الى غرف نومهم بل انه وبعد
اكثر من ست ساعات من الهجوم كانت تقديرات
القياده الجنوبيه تؤكد ان حماس ارسلت 200ي
مسلح فقط لمستوطنات
الغلاف حفل نوفا الموسيقي في رعيم كان
صوره ثانيه عن الغياب الامني الذي سبق
طوفان الاقصى لم يكن لدى الج الجيش
الاسرائيلي اي خطه لصد هجوم حماس بل ان
المؤسسه الامنيه بقيت لساعات طوال تحت
تاثير الصدمه والمفاجاه وامع اناا في
التخبط لجا الجيش الاسرائيلي لاجراء
هانيبال في صد هجوم المقاومه الفلسطينيه
فاصدر اوامر لسلاح المدفعيه بقصف الاسرى
والاسر وهو ما اكدته تحقيقات الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في بئيري حين قصفت الدبابات
الاسرائيليه بيتا تحصن فيه عده مقاتلين
كانوا يحتجزون 15 رهينه كشفت تحقيقات
الشرطه الاسرائيليه كذلك ان مروحيه عسكريه
تابعه للجيش اطلقت النار على المشاركين في
الحفل الموسيقي في رعيم خلال محاولتها
القضاء على مقاتلين لحماس في ذلك المكان
تم توثيق مقتل 360 شخصا يى نتنياهو بنفسه
عن تحمل اي مسؤوليه عن هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر بل سخر وسائل اعلام مقربه منه وحتى
عائلاته لالقاء المسؤوليه ل كاهل الجيش
والموساد والشباك محدثا حاله تراشق وشكوك
متبادله فيما وصفه بيوم الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر الخاص باسرائيل